[Music]
the Champagne region of France may have
reigned supreme in the world of
sparkling wine for centuries but
increasingly it's being given a run for
its money by one of its closest
neighbors England is now producing some
of the globe's finest sparkling wine
empty as tyub went to visit one
world-beating vineyard just an hour from
london if there is ever a movie scene
that captured the feeling of a glass of
fizz this might be it director Baz
Luhrmann's take on the Great Gatsby I'm
GATT with its eponymous hero you sure
knew how to throw a good party
[Music]
most of us think of the Champagne region
of France as the true home of bubbles of
distinction but sparkling wine Regents
are popping up all over the globe and
this unlikely landscape may be one of
the finest it's England whose rainy
southern counties are making some of the
best sparkling wines in the world what
we found is that the the Chardonnay from
this vineyard produced something quite
amazing
Matt sturgeon all managers this vineyard
in East Sussex that's won a lot of
awards and international trophies as
well so we know there's something quite
particular about this this patch here
that we're standing on award-winning
English wine isn't something you may
have heard about but that's what's being
created just an hour's drive outside of
London last year this vineyard Ridgeview
rattled the wine world by earning the
title of international winemaker of the
year for more than two decades the
Robert's family has been making
traditional methods sparkling wine from
three classic varieties which include
Chardonnay Pinot Noir and Pinot Meunier
bottles of bubbly so good who was served
to President Obama at Buckingham Palace
during a state banquet back in 2011
Simon Roberts is the head winemaker we
think this is a really good
interpretation of what we want an
English wines taste like so there's a
lot of fruit on the front pallets what
we think represents English spoken like
a hint of just how good this wine is
came in 2010 when it was up against
champagne in competition the winner is a
block - Blanca we like our wines they
only block to promise it and this wines
from England
Sussex and we looked dad and I looked at
each other like oh why a really big day
for which view I was also a really big
day for English Park and wine taking on
a French Champagne industry and winning
maybe partly due to this man
Chris Foss an English wine pioneer
honing his trade in Bordeaux he saw the
potential for an English wine trade and
established the world
Wine Education Center just down the road
from Ridge View how is English sparkling
Juan been received in the wine world
when you think of especially the old
world that they may look down their nose
a little bit you know people are
recognizing that the English wine
industry is one of the fastest growing
and most successful in the world now
what is it about the climate here that
lends to the production of sparkling
wine so a nice slow ripening under cool
temperatures and you get really you know
get fruit with a lot of flavor a lot of
subtlety a lot of character and I think
that's that's where we win out there are
now over 500 vineyards in southern
England with an annual production in
excess of 5 million bottles a trend not
lost on some of France's most
prestigious Champagne houses brands like
Taittinger and Bollinger have been
snapping up huge parcels of land in
southern England something few would
have ever dreamed of even a few years
ago back at Ridge View the Robert's
family plans to double production by the
end of the year every time you pour
yourself a glass of sparkling wine what
do you think to yourself do you just
think I can't believe we're here
sometimes I like to know a little taste
it that's right for CBS this morning
Saturday in Fiesta he Sussex in southern
England my toast next one me he's
surprised at his own success which is
really fun to see less and less people
are surprised now right yeah and how
well they're doing appears so who knew
England yeah for so long it was
champagne champagne champagne and now
it's open the doors for somebody else
it's still champagne - yeah we'll try
anything right